here's how a restaurant used mints to
make more money if you've ever seen
mints by the door at or restaurant
here's what that restaurant's doing
wrong and what you can use that same
psychology in your business to help all
of your employees make more money so
when they took the mints from the door
and actually gave them to the waitresses
to give out when they gave the bill they
all got increases in tips but the way
they gave them out actually changed how
much they got is the increase so when
they handed the bill with a mint they
got a three percent boost in tips when
they handed the bill with two mints they
got a 14 boost and the third version of
how they tried it was the best one they
handed the bill with one mint on it they
started to walk away and then they
turned around and came back and put
another mint on the platter and people
gave a 23 boost in tips and the reason
this works is something called
reciprocity people feel obligated to
give back to people when there's three
things that occur when someone gives
them a gift when it's personalized to
them and when it's unexpected and so if
you can weave those three things into
the gifts that you give you'll have
people feel far more obligated to comply
to the requests that you made and so if
you have a business and you have a way
of giving something to a customer
especially before they're about to make
a purchasing decision this is where you
can use the psychology tactic to make
more money